We have it checking words.
We have it-- well, first, we
have it limiting the input
to five-letter words.
And those are five-letter words
that actually are in the list.
So that's good.
And then, we have it checking
the correctness of each letter,
which is also good.
Although, there is one thing
that isn't quite right.
Let's see, the target word is--
oh, yeah so let's see, what's a
five-letter words but with two
letters that are
in the target word?
So if we have this word,
saves, that's my guess.
So these are all in
the right position--
the last three letters because
the target word is, gives.
But it's also saying
that there's an S here
that's in the wrong position.
And in the actual
word or game, it
would not say that this S
is in the wrong position
because that was already used
up-- that, S in the target word
is used up by this one that
was in the correct position.
I think what we need to do,
is we need to take two passes,
comparing the target word end--
the guess.
And the first pass
will just look
for the exact matches, where
they're in the right place.
And this will use up those
letters in the target word.
So if the target is
gives, we take one pass.
We find these three match.
And then, the only
remaining letters
are G and I. And then,
we take another pass,
and we'll check whether
these letters in the guess
are in those remaining
letters, G and I.
So, yes if these
remaining guess letters,
S and A are in the
remaining target letters.
OK so let's do that.
All right, so first we'll
take one pass over the word--
over the words, and just look
for the correct or the result.
We just look for places
where there are exact
matches in the correct position.
All right, and if they're not--
or sorry, if it is in
the correct position,
then we should mark
that letter is used up.
OK, so there's two
ways we could do that.
We could mark the letters
that in the target word
is being used up,
or we can actually
just keep track of
the remaining letters,
so that are not used up.
So let's do it that way.
I think, in this case, it
will be a little bit simpler.
So there's a target letter.
There's a guess.
There's also remaining.
Let's call these
remaining letters,
and character length 0.
OK, so if it's correct, great.
Else remaining-- and well, we
can grow the vector this way--
remaining, and just
that target letter,
we'll add it to the remaining--
the list of remaining letters.
OK, so that's our first
pass over the word.
And then, we'll take a
second pass over the word.
And I guess, let's
do the same thing.
Actually, this looks a
little bit better like that.
Iterating over the
letters in the guess.
Even though it's
effective, we've
seen it feels more
correct that way.
All right, so if--
you can actually
reuse this code here.
So if the guess is not,
or if it's not already
a correct result.
So we can say, it's
OK, if the guess does not
match the target letter here.
And the guess is in the
set of not target letters,
but remaining letters.
Then, we'll say the
result is in the word.
OK, and let me think about this.
We also need to-- in this case,
we actually need to remove that
remaining letter from--
we need to remove that letter
from the set of remaining
letters.
So let's try this here.
So if we say--
let's run this function.
OK, compare words,
target is gives,
and we're making a guess saves.
That totally did not work.
This logic is messed up here.
Oh, you know what
we can do, actually,
let's start the results, instead
of an empty character vector.
Let's start it with
a character vector,
where the starting value
is just not in the word.
And then, if we find
matches or if we
find correct letters
or inward letters,
then we'll replace that entry.
So let's say, we'll
do rep, not-in-word 5.
OK, so that creates a character
vector with a blank five
with all the same
value, not-in-word.
And that'll be our
starting value for results,
and then we'll replace
those entries as we iterate.
So, let's try this again.
Pair words gives and saves.
OK, that's right.
So previously, the
problem with saves,
it was-- the first s of
saves was in the word.
And now, it's saying
it's not in the word
because that's used up
by that the last s there.
But there could be a problem.
Yeah, all right, this
is not an actual word.
So this would not be
accepted by the whole app.
But we can test this
out by comparing--
we want one of these
G's to indicate--
Oh, actually, that's
actually not helpful.
So sorry.
This is a total nonsense
set of characters.
But what we're trying
to figure out here
is, we know that this S
will be marked as correct,
and it'll consume--
It'll use up the S
in the target word.
So that this first S will
not be marked S in word.
But will the same
thing happen for the G
when it's just in the word?
Like one of them should
be marked as in the word
but in the wrong place,
but not both of them.
But what's happening
is that they're both
being marked as in the word.
So we actually need to--
if we have this
match here, we need
to remove that guess letter
from a set of remaining letters.
I always have to try this out.
So let's say, match
for the match function.
What does this do?
Match returns-- OK,
this is, OK, good.
got a little lucky here.
So the match function I
always have to test it out.
And I think this is the
right order of arguments.
So I'm saying, hey, given
this letter and this vector
with a bunch of letters, What
is the first position where
this letter shows
up in the second?
The first thing shows
up in the second thing.
I think that right,
let me make sure.
The vector positions of
the first or the second.
I think that's right.
Let me just-- so if these are
all G, actually yeah, one.
OK great.
All right, so I can say,
remaining and give it
this index here.
So I say match where--
OK, so this is a way to
remove things from a vector.
So I can say--
and actually, why don't
we just try this out.
This is a good way to
test things out in R.
So, if I say, so remaining--
I'll just actually create
some variables locally,
and we'll test them
out in the council.
Remaining letters are G and I.
And let's say, guess is just G.
So it's a little
bit different here
from what we have here
because here we're
using guest bracket I, but let's
just take this code and remove
that.
So here we're going
to try to remove g
from the remaining vector.
That did not work.
Oh, you know what?
Sorry, there's a much
easier way to do this.
So-- oh, yeah.
There's a much easier
way to do this.
OK.
Sorry, this would have
worked if it was a list.
But it doesn't work
for character vectors
or for atomic vectors.
What we can say
is remaining is--
let's just take all of
the letters that are not
equal to that guess, all right?
OK.
So let's-- right.
Let's try this again.
Let's lift some just
example code here.
So remaining is g, i.
Guess is g and--
you can actually just print
this out without assigning it.
So--
Oh, yeah.
Got to get rid of that i.
So false and true.
So yes, it does match
this one, so that's false.
And it does not match
this one, so that's true.
So we say remaining, our guess
is not equal to remaining,
and that gives us just i.
And that is what we want.
Oh, no, that's
actually not true.
Because we only want to
remove one at a time, right?
So let's see.
But this will remove all of
the g's, if there's one--
if the guess has one.
So let me-- OK, I've got
to think about this again.
No, no.
OK, here it is.
Here it is.
So x minus 3 is there.
OK.
All right.
All right,
character-- let's see.
So we're going to go
back to the match thing.
So let's see, remaining--
Let's see.
How did we do that?
What did we do before?
Right, the index was--
OK.
We did-- so let me just do this.
We'll do match guess
comma remaining.
OK.
So let me just--
yeah, g and g.
Just, we want to make sure
that we just get one of them.
That's position 2.
That's the first match there.
So right.
So then what we want to say is
remaining bracket minus that.
OK.
So that removed that one entry.
That's what we want.
All right.
So let's do minus match, yes.
OK.
All right.
Let's try pair words.
Let's see if we can say--
we did that one.
That looks correct.
And then we also did-- if we
put a couple of g's in there,
we just want the first one
to say that it's in the word.
And that's right.
OK.
All right.
So now we've fixed up our
word comparison algorithm
by taking two passes.
And let's try it out.
OK.
So again, we still know
the target word is "gives."
And when we said aisle,
that looks right.
And if we say saves, great.
It's not marking this S as being
in the word, because we already
used it up.
All right, excellent.
OK.
Now we need to give it-- we
need to have it keep track,
like, accumulate all
the previous results
and keep printing that out.
So let's see.
Let's make sure if we
type in gives, great.
They're all right.
OK, cool.
So let's see.
I think the way that we can--
that we should do this is we
can actually just store the
results, the previous results,
in a vector--
or sorry, in a list.
So let's say-- let's create
a list called all_guesses.
And we don't have to do anything
fancy with reactivity here.
There may be cases
where that's useful.
But right now, we don't need it.
If we find that we need it,
then we can make that change.
But let's say
all_guesses is a list.
And every time
that somebody makes
a guess that makes
it past here, then
we will add that to
the all_guesses list.
Let's see.
We could store the whole--
all that information.
Yeah, let's do that.
Yeah.
So let's say all_guesses.
And let me put dollar guess.
OK.
And this is going
to be a string.
So actually, this is just
going to be a character
vector for right now.
Yeah, that's fine.
OK.
And then what we want to do is--
OK, well, this is not
the most efficient way,
but it's how we're
going to do it.
So we can do a--
sorry.
Right now, this is going
to store all the guesses,
but it's not going to
do anything with them.
It's still just going to
print out the most recent one.
But we also-- we wanted
to update this text box
with all of the
previous results,
or all the previous guesses.
So there's a number of
ways we can do that.
Again, I'm just going to
try to keep things simple.
So let's-- we're going to
append this most recent guess
to the all_guesses.
And then let's just
iterate over each of them
and do the check every--
sorry, we'll check each word.
And that's going to happen
every time somebody enters
in a new guess.
Again, this is not
super efficient,
but it's fine for what
we're doing right now.
So this time, I'm going
to use it needs to vapply.
So this is like applying a
function over many items.
So the items are all_guesses.
That's a function that takes
in that particular guess
and does something with it.
So let me just say--
we have to specify the
return type for vapply.
So format the results.
And then this will return
a character vector.
So each guess will
get this treatment,
where it returns a string
that looks like this,
and then we're going to
get that vector back,
and then we should
do something with it.
So but let's just
say out_string that.
And then let's
see if that works.
So let's guess aisle again.
And it saves.
Oh, that's replacement.
That's not what we want.
Oh, you know what?
We need to use a
double arrow here.
Because I was using
a single arrow,
it was just scoping
this assignment
within this
renderText block here.
So it wasn't actually modifying
this copy of all_guesses,
it was just modifying
a local copy of it.
So I need to use a
double arrow to make sure
that I'm modifying this copy
of all_guesses out here.
Let's try it again.
Aisle, saves.
OK.
Well, that's sort of right.
It's just sort of sticking
them next to each other.
And remember, this is
a character vector.
And what we want
to do with it is--
well, actually, why don't
we-- let's take a look at it.
This can be a handy tip here.
So you can stick in a
browser statement here,
which will take it to the--
it'll go into the R debugging
console every time it
hits that line of code.
So let's reload the app.
Let's say-- again, let's do
the same guesses, aisle, go.
OK.
Now, it hasn't printed
anything out here,
but we are in a console,
an R console that's
stopped right here.
So we can say, what is
this out_string thing?
OK, it's actually-- it's this--
it's a character vector.
It looks like it's a named
vector, which doesn't
matter for our purposes.
And that's the content.
OK, great.
That looks like that.
Now if we make another
guess, saves, say out_string.
And it's a character vector
with two items in it.
And we actually want that--
them to be printed one
on top of each other.
So let's just-- let's
say paste out_string,
collapse equals backslash n.
So that's what we want.
There's a backlash n,
a new line right there.
If we want to see what
it would look like,
we can use cat on that string.
So that's what we want to
come out here, all right?
So let's do-- let's take this
and put it in here, save that.
I'm going to quit this
debugging console.
You can do it by clicking
Stop or capital Q.
And we'll delete that
browser statement there
and so we don't keep doing that.
And let's run the app all right.
Aisle, saves, gives.
Ooh, pretty good at this.
[LAUGHS]
[CHORD ARPEGGIO]